دكتور لقاء مكي يعني ما رايك في هذه
المعطيات حتى الساعه وكل ذلك حتى الان
نقلا عن مسؤولين امريكيين وليست بيانات من
البيت الابيض ولا من البنتاجون ولكن هناك
قصف وهناك استهداف لمواقع عده يقال بان
ايضا القائم كما ذكر عامر لافي جر
استهدافها يعني هي الشيء الوحيد غير
الطبيعي حتى اللحظه هو عدم الاعلان الرسمي
من قبل الولايات المتحده لانه كل هذه
الضربات كانت متوقعه والسيناريوهات
المطروحه خلال الايام الماضيه منذ الحادث
اللي حصل الاسبوع الماضي ضد القوات
الامريكيه هو طرح هذا الم يعني بالضبط ما
يجري الان وما هو اكثر من ذلك والتوقيت
ايضا بعد جنازات الجنود الامريكيين
الثلاثه ضحايا الهجوم قبل اسبوع او
ايام هو كان متوقع بعد بعد الجنازه يعني
بعد تشيعهم ومشاركه الرئيس الامريكي ان
يكون هناك الرد لذلك هو هي يعني على
الاغلب هي الضربه الامريكيه المتوقعه ولا
اعتقد انه اسرائيل الان ستتداخل يعني
اسرائيل عاده تضرب المناطق القريبه من
يعني من دمشق من الحدود من الجولان هذه
المناطق التي تؤثر اكثر لكن هذه المناطق
على الاغلب هي الضربات الامريكيه التي
كانت منتظره ولكن هناك مسؤول من بوليتيكو
يعني قال بان احدى الضربات لم تكن امريك
هل تتوقع التحالف من هو التحالف هي
القياده امريكيه يعني ليس هناك اعتقد من
سيقوم بالضربات غير الولايات المتحده ولا
تحتاج الولايات المتحده يعني لانه دفاع عن
النفس بالنهايه هو ليس مثلا مكافحه
الارهاب امريكا قالت انها ستضرب في الوقت
المناسب وبالطريقه المناسبه لم تقل ل نضرب
هذه مساله محسومه سيضربون وهناك
سيناريوهات تم تسريبها للصحف الامريكيه
بشكل واضح ووزير الدفاع تحدث ضرباه ستكون
قويه ومتعدده ولايام متعدده ا ولكن يعني
هي كما جرى ذكره حتى الان نقلا عن مسؤولين
امريكيين حول نوعيه هذه الضربات وحتى
الساعه لا بيانات كما ذكر مراسلنا وايضا
كما تحدثت وكما تابعنا بطبيعه الحال هذه
الضربات هي مرح مرحله اولى وستستمر لعده
ايام
وستستهلك نعم لاي درجه هذه المرحله الاولى
من حيث هذه الكميه من هذه مجموعه الضربات
والمواقع المستهدفه هي مرحله متقنه مدروسه
مثلا زمانيا ومكانيا اي ودقيقه حتى الساعه
كما تابعت دكتور لقاء اذا لاحظتي انه
الفتره اللي مضت منذ الهجمه يعني على
القاعده البرج 22 ا واضح جدا ان الامريكان
اخذوا وقتهم في تحديد الاهداف هم اصلا
لديهم بنك اهداف لكن وهذا كان المفروض
موجود منذ مده طويله يعني دوما يتم تحديث
البنك لكن هم يختارون من بنق الاهداف ومن
سناريوهات متعدده يختار الرئيس الامريكي
ما يجري الحدود يعني حدود الضربه هل هي
ضربه رادعه كما يجري مثلا في البدايه مع
الحوثي ضربه لمواقع محدده ام ضربه تدميريه
ام ضربه انتقاميه وهكذا في الولايات
المتحده خلال الفتره الماضيه كان التركيز
من قبل النخب السياسيه على ضربه انتقاميه
لا رادعه ان تكون تدميريه ومن الواضح انه
هناك ما بين هذا وذاك الان بعد اللي حصل
الخط الاحمر اللي تمت عبوره في العلاقه ما
بين ايران وتماس بين ايران والولايات
المتحده اعتقد ان واشنطن اتخذت قرار
بتوجيه ضربه هي لن تدمر كل شيء لانه اصلا
هم انسحبوا من مواقعهم يعني القيادات
السوريه حسب رويترز ا القياده الايرانيه
الرئيسيه سحبت الى ايران والقيادات حتى
بالفصائل مثلا في العراق اختفت يعني تم
مثلا افراغ عدد كبير من المقرات واختيار
مواقع بديله حزب الله الكتاب حزب الله
العراق طلع بيان بايقاف العمليات بمعنى
حتى المواقع الالكترونيه لهم توقفت وهي
مواقع على النت يعني هذا معناه ان هم لم
يعودوا في وارد الوجود في مكان معين كي
يستهدفون وهذا امر طبيعي مت
لذلك هو الامر ل يعني لن لن يكون سوى
تدمير مقرات لكن فيها رسائله واضحه وهذا
ما تريده واشنطن رساله للداخل الامريكي ان
بايدن رئيس مقاتل يستطيع ان يسترد الهيبه
الامريكيه وان يدافع عن الولايات المتحده
في اذا قتل جنودها او تعرضت مصالحها لخطر
وهاي مهمه جدا في سنه انتخابيه هو يعير
بانه رئيس ضعيف والامر الثاني للخارج ان
انها تعدت اذا ما افترضنا ايران كانت وراء
الضربه كما تقول واشنطن ا فتعدد خطوط
الحمر وبالتالي عليها ان تنتبه للضربه
التالي قد تكون في ايران نفسها هذا الامر
يجب ان لا يتعدى الحد الذي يصل الى حرب
شامله هذا هو الهدف